so let's talk about Elisa heinershide
Budweiser's VP of marketing she's having
a rough few weeks right she hired female
impersonator Dylan Mulvaney to sell beer
when she should have listened to me and
hired this guy
[Laughter]
with Jared but if by some chance you're
not caught up it started April 1st after
Mulvaney AKA Peewee her him
Bud Light
picture on it
April Fool's joke like when I told those
orphans I was adopting them
price is suffering in the past two weeks
Anheuser-Busch has lost 5 billion with a
b as in b cup
people haven't been this disgusted by an
ad since OJ endorsed steak knives
so 5 billion lost how do you like them
Adam's apples
this never happened to Spuds McKenzie
was played by a female dog so he was
actually bud light's first transgender
spokesman
or spokeswoman technically a spokes
difference between spuds and Dylan spuds
had a black eye but Mulvaney gave the
brand a black eye and spuds was lovable
Mulvaney's an annoying rash that won't
go away which brings us back to Elisa
heinershide just before the Mulvaney
debacle blew up she said this
I had a really clear job to do when I
took over a Bud Light and it was this
brand is in Decline it's been in Decline
for a really long time so her job was to
what put the brand out of its misery
like a horse with a broken leg
mission accomplished Secretariat
what well at least one Clydesdale still
has a job but
she also
she also said this oh take me now
Bud Light had been kind of a brand of
Friday kind of out of touch humor and it
was really important that we had another
approach
the new approach alien alienate those
very fratty people from buying her
product mission accomplished again Bud
Light could have put out a statement
saying some cans were tainted with
monkey pox and they wouldn't have lost
this much money
instead they found a joker who wears
sports bras in bubble baths I'm sorry
Frat Boys hardly ever wear sports bras
in the tub even when I offer them an
extra 20 bucks
hell bud why not finish the job and hire
Meghan Markle to be the king of beers
and now Bud's throwing their VP under
the bus over the whole thing blaming a
low-level marketing staffer claiming the
bigwigs had no idea themselves I've seen
such desperate ass covering since Brian
stelter split his pants at the Golden
Corral
[Laughter]
better The Daily Caller did some digging
and apparently heinershide is an expert
when it comes to fratty behavior check
out these pictures from 2006 on our now
deleted Facebook page here she is
getting fratty with some Rolling Rock
which might even be frattier than Bud
Light and I suspect there was some
fratty Behavior leading up to this
snapshot
yeah hashtag fratty as
and here's a Heiner's side blowing up a
condom like a balloon which is how I got
fired from being a birthday party clown
Freddy or not fratty I don't know and
whatever is going on here that's what
Dylan Mulvaney thinks he looks like
but really all that stuff is fine she
was a college student at the time so
what hell the name heinershide even
sounds like a German beer she was just
having fun the problem is that now as
awoke sanctimonious creative performing
her woke duties she decided to poop on
more parties than Joe Biden in a bouncy
castle
fact is she was once one of the fun
people that she's now turning her back
on and now Bud Light sales are
plummeting like a hot air balloon
carrying the cast of The View
so
applauding the death of The View
you guys but look I'm almost over this
story but not quite I actually feel a
little bad for Dylan there's nothing
worse than becoming a story during a
slow news cycle and I bet the decision
to hire her was just some Dopey kid out
of college who thought it would be cool
to throw some trans into the faces of
these fat old white beer drinkers and if
you don't like it you got to be bigoted
but if you tell millions of people that
your product isn't intended for them
anymore what do you think is going to
happen they'd rather chug water from Don
lemon's hot tub
yeah
and only woke sheep like drones would
think it's wise to insert a lecture into
a party beverage and so Bud paid for it
something companies should consider the
next time they weigh throwing their
consumers under the woke bus people will
see through it they no longer care if
you think it's transphobic to criticize
a company that openly insults you and
it's not transphobic to mock the worst
spokesperson since Bill Cosby tried to
sell us Jello pm
wow yeah Jello pm
in fact if you held back your criticism
because the person is trans then really
isn't that textbook transphobia it means
you're scared to speak your mind to them
which is exactly what the woke wants
[Applause]
eight in six figures to stay away from
their products comedian and co-host of
the Jim Norton and Sam Roberts show on
SiriusXM Jim Norton
he's on a 12-step program to give up
crumpets Fox News contributor Douglas
Murray
he gets hate mail from carbs Fox News
contributor cats him
and finally his ring size is hula hoop
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyra
Jim there's a lot of interesting threads
to this story uh you've got you've got
marketing you've got a product you've
got an interesting choice but let's get
to brass tacks you find Dylan Mulvaney
attractive don't you I would say
I like trans girls hate influencers so
I'm kind of caught in the middle here
um but no I'm not big on Dylan but I I
think this is such a funny story to me
how mad people are like this is not it
this is a product that makes you pee
your pants and drive the wrong way on
the highway and people are so upset I
don't think they're marketing against
people they're just trying to Market to
other people and I think that that woman
made a mistake when she acted holier
than thou and criticized the the Friday
humor she should have just said yeah we
want young trans people to drink this
product my identity is not wrapped up in
who else drinks a beverage I drink yeah
like I like Diet Coke I wouldn't care if
Hitler was on the can I would drink diet
he was high-fiving Bin Laden I'd be like
I'd like a Diet Coke please and I'd
rushed the little mustache hairs off and
I would enjoy my entire Coke
my identity is not tied in with other
people who enjoy a beverage I enjoy I
have to say though you said something
that no one else has said and it totally
it's the answer to everything it's not
about trance it's about influencers
there's not a single likable influencer
it changes people by making them hyper
dramatic and so you can't like them even
it doesn't matter who it is you just
can't stand them well they don't have
everything trans has to be campy like it
doesn't have to be like I'm a lady like
how about
like the show Laverne Cox Laverne Cox
where Trace lazette just drinking a Bud
Light like that's a perfectly fine ad
yeah but they have to make everything
campy and over the top and it becomes
irritating but it doesn't bother me that
somebody transes on I just don't care no
yeah me neither it doesn't bother me
either but also why are all these
examples always male to female trans
people right yes yes like I don't care
who's on the can either it's like I I'm
not offended I'm not worked up by it but
I feel like they're saying that you have
to be born with a penis to drink Bud
Light because it is a bro brand it's
really super broey but like I'm broey
yeah you are 365 days of being a bro
have a female to male trans person 365
days of being a bro and now I'm crushing
Brew of the bruising my bro skis yo
who's the perfect one Bono like why
should have been Chaz Bono you're
talking about Chaz sure it's it's just I
Dylan is not a bud it doesn't fit the
Bud Light brand regardless of gender you
know Douglas you come from England where
beer is soup right what beer is soup
what do you mean it's dark it's thick
they say it's part of the food group
yeah it's uh it's it's warm and thick
yeah yeah but you so do you consider Bud
Light an actual uh a beer very vaguely
yeah but I wanted to see Dylan elevating
after drinking all those butterflies I
wanted to see like I wanted to see the
last take after chugging them all back
because of course of course the Mulvaney
isn't drinking them and the thing about
it all is it's just so cynical it's just
the thing about woke corporations and
things it's just the cynicism most of us
don't like I don't care what anyone
drinks I don't want I don't care if Bud
Light want to try to make more trans
people alcoholics whatever they want to
do to do their brand but what I mind
about it is just this idea that you've
just gotta you've got to have things
forced in your face it's like it's what
makes most you know films and things
kind of unwatchable it's just kind of
you will accept the the ideas we're
putting on you better you better love it
you better stand up and clap with a tear
in your eye exactly yeah just like this
season's uh what's what's the Kardashian
uh Kim no the the only one who wasn't
famous for being a woman who became a
woman oh
yeah Caitlyn Jenny yeah it's like um
dinner more of endings this season's
Caitlyn Jenner
Caitlin is an actual hero the point is
well and we're being more plausible Bud
Light Drinker yes but oh but you know
Caitlyn could put it back but you know
of course
you mean drink drink a lot yes drink
yeah but watch the beer Caitlyn Caitlyn
could drink about like they'd crush it
and I'm Raw yeah but the point is is
that you know there's that there was
that season where just uh he just won
everything yeah sports Personality Woman
of the Year glamor person of the year
and it's the same for this guy at the
moment it's just like it's just not too
much it's on everything she's annoying
uh it just we don't need it on
everything it bothers me too Tyrus
because it the more we talk about Dylan
the less we talk about the Canadian shop
teacher well it's the same thing no
because you can't talk about
you can't talk about the same thing
twice yeah because I'm Different I am
offended yeah that Dylan's on the can
for one reason he's not representing
trans women he's not he's he's a
performance actor he's in Woman face
that's like you trying to tell me it's
cool if someone painted their face black
and was put them on the face of the can
of Bud Light and tell me well he's
representing black no it's not I am
offended women should be offended men
should be offended these are our mothers
that are being made to made fun of the
stupid women are stupid and dumb and
public that's not a trans woman that's
not Caitlyn Jenner Caitlyn Jenner lives
her life as a woman and not at the
expense of other women yeah she just
wants a privately be who she wants to be
and she has every right to do that and I
will drink a keg of beer with Caitlyn
Jenner Anytime Anyplace
but this is blackface in his room
there you go
that is going to be on my bucket list
what's that getting wasted with Kate
Caitlyn Jenner I can make the call yeah
let's do it yeah let's go and just do a
whole weekend of getting weight we'll
golf I never said anything about
drinking with you oh I said Kate oh no
no no no no
and he does 20 minutes of should I go
should I stay
a driver like me does he not like me I
can't do that again all right Cat Knows
Equity they applaud from data that's a
fraud
that was good
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else